bis zum morgen ich werde gebraucht sagt
yvette geboxt geboxt
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen projekte
minecraft und zwar micro war oh das ist
so hardcore mäßig dies das was genau das
ist kann euch den kinos jetzt mal sagen
weil das ist mein team partner high
higher in minecraft war oh das ist die
mega verschärfte hardcore youtube
survival games hunger games edition die
es jemals gab
das heißt wir spielen quasi eine riesige
runde angegeben sind mit den kisten da
könnt ihr gleich entweder hinlaufen ich
der club an der ganzen sache wenn man
ein einziges mal stirbt ist man komplett
raus aus dem projekt es gibt keinen
respawn oder so was wie das beispiel ob
der fall war keine eine folge aussetzt
wenn man tot ist ist man tot und somit
ist das projekt für denjenigen genau und
was ist unsere taktik unsere taktik ist
ganz einfach wir haben in der mitte
kisten was schreiben ihr eigentlich
wieder alle irgendwie meint es ja auch
egal jedenfalls wir sind hier in der
mitte auf jeden fall überall kisten
verteilt wo dann gesagt video oder coole
sachen holen wieder so drin sind die
schwerter und es kann auch sein dass
einfach nur crêpes drin liegt und so was
alles aber wir haben eine andere taktik
welche da wäre klotz da wir ja beide
ausgeschriebene pvp profis sind und auch
schon immer waren und wenn man zumindest
bei mir nach rechts schaut und expert
stegen durch könnte ein bisschen
gefährlich werden und jetzt geht es in
einer minute los so eine minute haben
deswegen haben wir uns dazu entschieden
dass wir nicht das risiko eingehen
werden dort in die mitte zu rennen denn
dort ist zwar was zu essen was jetzt auf
der 1.75 verliert man janika sprunger
und die spieler park und können daran
sterben deswegen das hat priorität
nummer 120 essen zu besorgen aber es
lohnt sich glaube ich nicht für uns
beiden jetzt hier das risiko auf sich zu
nehmen die mitte zu rennen deswegen
werden wir versuchen möglichst schnell
irgendwie von von dem ganzen pulk
wegzukommen und uns ja irgendwo ein
kleines lager hin wie viel viel schon
eigentümlich aufgeschlagen
dieses befürchten ist dass wir direkt in
dieser folge sterben werden weil ich all
das ist das schlimme ist dass erwarten
ja ok
wir laufen jedoch dahin dahin ja ja ja
ich einfach laufen lässt du mir nach
oder ich lasse mir nach ich glaube die
luft bevor aus deinen hintern ist wieso
kommt jetzt nicht 98 71 g/t gold vor der
sonne stark haltenden abgucken so los
geht's los geht's los gehts stege und
stimme laufen auch weg lasst ihr land
ich werde direkt bei manroland wollte
direkt geboxt wo bist du gut ist sowieso
interviews hinter ihnen gleich hinter
die ringer läuft hinterher und boxt ich
nehm ich boxe niemand aber irgendwie
läuft hinterher auf jeden fall das ist
das cast crafter bist du bist da bist du
bist am morgen bis ich was mister morgen
ich werde die fed gebracht gemobbt wird
geboxt geboxt chodorkowskis weiteres
auto hat sie es nicht gepackt fett
gebacken alter hilft mit roskilde jsc
jsc nowitzki lässig wer war jesus ich
weiß wo du bist was du isst wurde war
der wagen war direkt da war der weg ich
habe ich habe ihn ja wenig haben
mister morgue wo bist du bist doch
piloten glauben ich muss hier runter
ohne irgendwie heftigen schaden
dazu kommt dass ihre ruhe ansonsten hier
kommt lasst uns was ist los also es ist
eigentlich hat das ganze projekt in
dieser freien ziel den charakter ich
musste jetzt also eigentlich weiter
angreifen aber natürlich wichtig ist
dass ich hier den den den kali mine
gekommen alter wirklich mein herz meine
puppe geht mir auch wie sonstwo machen
halt manchmal holstein sperre und so
krass ich mache am besten und ich guck
auf irgendwie wie jemand macht erstmal
da nicht irgendwie laufen laufen laufen
laufen laufen
die comcom das irgendwo hin da hinten
wird doch wohl irgendwie läuft hinter
mir okay ich glaube ich ziemlich weg
knacken können aber ja
breite ich ja ich wollte wollte da gnade
vor recht ergehen lassen weil ansonsten
ist die aufeinander aufpassen dass ich
schon jemand tot
ich weiß es nicht keine ahnung ich hatte
noch drei leben chaos
ja ich hab dir hier ein schweinefleisch
nehmen das mal kein alter noch mehr
fleisch naja da gehen wir jetzt gleich
zu den schweinen offenes stein später ja
also normalerweise hätte man jetzt
gucken müssen dass man irgendwie in den
kampf geht aber wenn eben ein team
partner schon fast tot ist ist es nicht
sinnvoll wenn ich da jetzt noch bis zum
morgen ewigkeiten her gerannt wäre
deswegen hab ich das mal gelassen ich
kann kein holz abbauen oder wie
doch jetzt geht's du kannst ja ich kann
auch nicht holzabbau es läge der otto
falckenberg einzubauen oder wie alter
hatte ich radien stockmann ohne bis ich
hatte auch mega das lag total grad
das leckt mega richtig übel sogar ja ich
hatte ich beging tut mir ging total die
pumpe da oben ist im übrigen schon
wieder jemand da kommen so prime und so
wo bist du kommst du ich sehe dich sehe
ich sehe dich kate ausgeht - wohin
prozent ident
wir sind sind direkt da lass das mal
schnell über wasser das ist doch echt ja
super älter als wollten wir uns hier
holz holen und das zeug legt dann wie
sollen das dann jeder leider einfach weg
und es lag so heftig eine wenn das
server ruckelt wo bist du bist du mir ja
wirklich ich habe glaube ich ein impuls
der dann nicht mehr ich hab nur noch
drei leben ich hab nur noch drei beine
klatschen also nur 33 tieren das schwein
ich kokott hier irgendjemand kommt
versuch mal passieren kann kleinholz
abbauen immer noch sind scheiße dahinter
man auch richtig viele schweine aber wir
haben einfach keins mitgenommen ja das
problem
da kam mir dann gereinigt habe ich ja
schon eine ferne habe ich sie gesehen
hier sind noch mehr erscheine er soll es
sollte schon laufen aber das label hält
sich lange als ewig die platz zu machen
wenn sie ruckeln ich hab's - mal zwei
schweine bekommen etwa schweinefleisch
ich habe richtig angst hass von
irgendeiner seite einer kommt weiß dabei
weil bei ihr lachen verloren und gesetz
halten tagaus aber hier ist einfach tot
von der scheiße mann ich kann einfach
keine häuser bauen
ja das ist die können da alle häuser
bauen
das ist total okay jetzt glaube ich aber
dass spanien noch fertig und dann doch
du kannst holzer bauen das dauert noch
jahre bis das daraus kommt ja du musst
dann nur raten du musst die ganzen
holzblöcke ist einmal kaputt machen
quasi ach so tatsächlich da ist das auch
einer den hut er gibt mir das mal da in
darmstadt holz das gebiet ist mal
hierher schon jetzt einfach auf pass auf
dich auf
ich halte ausschau aber man die haben
wir an die ersten paar minuten überlebt
conny wir haben die hessen beim jungen
er das auch schon gedacht warum lesen
sie warum leben wir noch aha danke schön
auch gott jetzt jetzt fühle ich mich
schon mal eine ganze ganze ecke kommt
sammelt teenager so viel männlicher auf
jeden fall ja vor allem weil ich das so
gut geht das land ja ich hab ich hab's
das ist das mindeste über dem server
also es sind auch schon einfach mal
sieben minuten um kilos und es kommt mir
vor als ob man eine halbe sekunde
ich hab das ich hab das holz werde das
wird mich das duo wird hoffentlich
gefixt
das weiß ich wann hast du noch wie viel
leben hast du noch ich hab noch volles
leben und vollen vollen hunger wir
sollten jetzt vielleicht sogar mal die
kraftilanti bewegen uns noch ein
bisschen bei der zornig und so vor
direkt an andern seite war ja passt mal
auf das war keine aktion welche
malsachen abbauen wir müssen auf jeden
fall die ganze zeit beisammen bleiben
ok außerdem hat jetzt kurz neben stehen
bleiben bis der halt so weg ist alles
gelegen den lecks adressiert auf jeden
fall noch besser drauf ich mal seine
lose ware hier wird gleich noch einen
roller fallen brauche ich mal moment im
kampf für müssen kurz warten wieder
hielt ankommt ist werden wir dann
rundenbasiert dass man nicht so schnell
sprinten auf ihren wie alt bin ich bin
auch hat er so angedient laufen langsam
laufen nebenbei hier die ganzen nebenbei
auf jeden fall schaden bekommen sehr
stark es ist auch super jahre alte profi
hat schon über euch wieder knapp ein
anderes tier am besten einen vogel den
münchenern klatsch
zudem ist aber ganz gut geregelt ich
verstehe immer noch nicht warum warum
ist am ehesten pharma hat weil man weiß
ist nicht so ich kenne ihn ja das hat in
der stadt aber noch zu jung crafter
haile stars lucio dann ist er hier
direkt hinter hinter dir
up grades sichersten ist es auf den
bäumen oder würde ich jetzt mal
behaupten ja ja ja ja wir können uns
bekundet hat gut umschauen der boden
über die a6 war jetzt auch wirklich
keinen einzigen gegner in unserer nähe
das unter sich jemand ich sehe jemandem
recht venus kommt zu mir hier oben drauf
ich habe gerade jemanden ferne gesehen
da in die richtung siehst du mich da wo
ich jetzt mal wieder war der wurde war
ja dass das könnte ja immer noch zornig
und so sein dass die da vielleicht dann
sollten wir uns vielleicht mal wirklich
einfach weiter bewegen oder vielleicht
gehört mir und so eine basis machen so
irgendwie aber leider weg ich möchte
mich das möchte erst weiter von der
mitte weg ja okay du bist das nächstes
gratis dazu unangenehm und vielleicht
einen kleider die die schweine noch
weiter klar mit mir einfach mal so ein
gewissen essen zu sprinten ok ok ok ok
und die da hinten ist ein ganzes schwein
herde das nämlich ganz cool wenn wir
direkt lassen der nächsten schweineherde
auf jeden fall hingehen hier und immer
mal ein bisschen nach hinten gucken dass
da nicht auf ihr klar sein
ich find bisher machen wir das richtig
stark
heute tut echt sind schon leute tot
gemacht frist habe ich nämlich gar nicht
mitbekommen ja ich hätte ja fast
minister morgen den förstl gemacht aber
mister morten schuldt ist mir
ganz viel das ist das wichtigste dass
für schweine bekommen und diese sei ich
habe 13
ich habe auch jetzt anders ist richtig
stark das richtig richtig geil
sie werden weiter und dann dann graben
wir uns vielleicht möglichst bald
irgendwie runter sammeln uns ärzte um
auch rüstungen zu machen dann ist das
glaube ich ganz ganz vorbei das ist echt
aber das ist das war ja damals bei hero
war das schon immer unglaublich krass
mit diesem mit diesem pvp gefühl aber
hier ist meine fünf ecken kassel hat
einfach das projekt vorbei ist wenn du
stirbst das ist das ist die absolute
härte aber okay ich bin noch voll
angespannt vom anfang alter ja ich hätte
ihr ganz ehrlich wäre echt gedacht du
stirbst du dich gleich mit das ist das
ist vorbei ich hatte sie zunächst
übrigens naja ich sehe dass da gleich
das auto stoppen also jetzt bei 11
minuten und leute ja zwei minuten machen
wir noch und und dann wegen seiner
familie auf drei minuten machen so
möglichst gut mal nicht kurz aber auf
jeden fall so dass es nicht 15 minuten
an wird weil man darf jetzt nicht so
krass und dann fangen wir nicht wieso da
einfach gleich an hier und vielleicht
ist das schon untergegangen
die ersten schon oder eines anderen
kohle das ist auch ganz gut
ja das ist aber wir sind in einem tollen
gebiet das ist das cms die ersten
letzten schon lasst uns mal hier am
besten hier einfach ausmachen kenia und
erwarte ich mir kürzlich eine kugel
fertig die bedienung und google gut weg
doch da war die krasse ganz euch
gefallen hat lassen bewertung dar
das ja haben überlegt werde erwartet
dass wir beide das überhaupt über über
die ersten fünf teams schafften das ok
alles klar bis zum nächsten mal
ok macht's gut